the Joe Rogan experience yeah anyway so
yeah so Amazon's doing business with
with the new door yeah that's kind of
yeah tick tops at Chinese company
already right and no is there some talk
I mean they've been making efforts you
know to limit the ability for tick tock
to do business you know like I think the
US military's is instructed all
personnel to stay off a tick tock you
know or not the interesting really yeah
again because of the same concern the
whole idea is this platform because you
know these these companies can argue all
they want to that they're independent
from the Chinese you know authorities
but ultimately the Chinese authorities
knock on their door and say we would
like access to your database because we
want to Hoover up all the information
about every US military person you know
that's stationed wherever or you know
they're gonna do it they're trying to
get one of the top tik-tok executives in
here really yeah
interesting now I don't even understand
Tech Talk I mean I know the kids kids
usually kids like it look at this make
Tic Tac videos it's considered a cyber
threat tenant Colonel Robin and army
spokeswoman told military comm we do not
allow it on government phone there you
go that a cyber threat an effective tool
for reaching young people of generation
how old is Generation see they're 12
what my daughter is 11 it's [ __ ] all
about tick-tock yeah teaching me
tick-tock dances I'm learning but my
daughter literally she thinks it's
hilarious she's teaching me tick-tock
dances and we practice for like [ __ ]
half an hour well how is it is it just
another version of like little videos
okay little videos but my 11 year olds
really into it yeah runs all think it's
hilarious I was gonna say I Drive I
Drive the slow go to his basketball
practices and occasionally there's you
know two or three other knuckleheads in
the car and they're all that's all
they're doing is they're talking of
comparing tik-tok videos or anything
weird yeah yeah I can't I can't
I'm too busy I'm not interested YouTube
started as just a cat videos and tell
I know it's 15 minute videos and now
it's whatever it is jump on board James
just saying it's a do you think I should
jump on board you shouldn't not jump on
board let me ask you this isn't oneplus
isn't that a Chinese company as well
find out one plug because oneplus is
accepted right
I mean oneplus monsters a lot of things
they make really high-end phones as well
how come they don't get the same kind of
scrutiny
I suspect they they do it just hasn't
hit the press and me tick tock blew up I
guess as a app that well kids you know I
can so it became but I didn't realize
generate how again how old is Generation
Z is that a like a 20 I don't even know
what that is it's below Millennials it's
like the next next thing whatever so
it's below Millennials okay that's when
we're really [ __ ] with that's when we
really get to see the fruits of our
labor you know not to disappear our
rabbit hole but I agree I think we have
no idea we have no idea what technology
is how it's going to impact in the long
run we don't have enough of a test case
yet right and I can look at my kids in
there it just within my little microcosm
of my three little dudes they're sort of
their attention span right and their
ability to and you can see it impacting
it and you can see it impact the way
that they study the way they learn the
way that and I don't think we're you
know again I'm not a Luddite you know
but I don't know that we're doing
ourselves any favors right and I don't
think there are we're doing ourselves
favors either and I don't think there's
any way of pulling back from him mm-hmm
there's no like you could tell your kids
to pull back you can maybe get your
friends kids to pull back but culturally
no one's pulling back from this stuff
it's they're getting more and more
immersed in their phones more and more
immersed in apps and Internet and in
this big if the big thing is apps to me
they all get on these little social
media apps like whether it's tic toc or
whatever it is yeah and they're all
direct messaging and looking at each
other's stuff and it becomes a giant
part of your life you know these kids
like you look at their for like my
daughter has friends that don't have any
restrictions on their phones my daughter
is like a time limit on her phone one
hour in the whole day right other
you know you have to do yeah you have to
do that but she's got a little friend
that doesn't have any time and this
little friend like you would think this
girl like her [ __ ] skin is growing
onto this phone she never goes anywhere
without this phone in her hand and she's
always looking at it like she can't talk
to anybody for five seconds without
looking at her phone checking tick-tock
checking that but that's what she
getting that from her parents and people
see I mean I mean how many times have
you sat in a restaurant and everybody
the table stared at they're from yeah
right or you get into I got on the car
rental bus today and I dropped my bag on
the thing and I stood there and I looked
down that bus and everybody was there at
the font yeah I mean at least that's
dead time right you just sitting on a
bus waiting to get to those let's check
my email real quick that makes sense
that's not a bad time to use your phone
in the old days you'd start up a
conversation with the guy next year so
oh you're from Omaha huh and now you
wouldn't know where I was going with
that you could but then you want
Homeland Security do you see anything
suspicious yeah this [ __ ] guy talked
to me on the bus yeah I don't know what
that's all about he wanted something he
referred to as a conversation that's my
favorite if you see anything suspicious
call this number
everything suspicious yeah see something
say something yeah
[Applause]